do you remember what it was like for you
at the world premiere of the Danish girl
I had my mom on my left and Eddie on the
bride we were all holding hands because
Eddie and I hadn't seen the final
version there at the premiere and it's
always a quite terrifying thing hi
Alyssia welcome to the show thank you
I'm really happy to see you here 2015
was such a crazy year for you because
you had five or so movies that came out
but they were movies that you shot over
a three and a half year period but some
of them didn't come out for a long time
that must have been so strange for you
yeah I was I mean it ended up being a
very much a coincidence or they will
come out at the same time and it was
funny I had my mum visiting over the
Golden Globes weekend and she said you
know I had friends you know back home
before before the beginning of last year
because they were like yeah we know that
Ellis have been filming you're working
but they were like we really haven't
seen anything what has she actually been
doing it hasn't really been working out
no that's like how did that work so yeah
that was kind of just how it happened
you mentioned your mother your mother is
a stage actress is she one of your main
inspirations for what you're doing now
she was the one who introduced me to the
whole world of theatre and acting and in
a very just natural way because I was I
was there watching her out in the wings
why when I grew up and I was it was it
was just a very natural thing what has
her reaction been to all of the great
performances you've had in the last year
but particularly to your role as Gerda
in the Danish girl it was one of those
times I mean they I'd love to talk to my
parents about what I do but I don't
think I've ever had and they would never
push anything but they were how's it
going with that did you go to that
audition and no how did it go and yeah
we would definitely think that that
would be that would be a good one to do
well I'm glad they approved it the
decision I'm glad they liked it I want
to take a look at what I think is the
most powerful scene of you and Eddie
Redmayne in the Danish girl this is a
moment where your character Gerda has
come back from an art show a very
important moment in her life and it's
quite an upsetting moment and it
a powerful moment so let's take a look
and talk about it the Danish girl you
should have been there how could I look
at me not everything it's about you what
did you do in the moments leading up to
the minute that you shot this to really
get into the place that you needed to be
funny I just remember I stood there in a
corner and I was really nervous and
actually I remember that it helped but
then I remember that it's interesting
how you build up that kind of those
nerves and then it's also it's a
wonderful thing where you make those
scenes and it was not every take the one
or two once suddenly you can you're so
in it and and Eddie or so wonderful I
think this was one of the scenes when I
remember that I was like that is Lily
standing in front of me and it was the
the thing of seeing what was so obvious
and what she knew was Lily in front of
her and also how to express her truths
emotionally which was I miss my husband
and the guilt within that knowing that
that is not the truth and how can I say
that to my person that I love who's now
truly obviously Lily mm-hmm well let's
see how it continues I need to see her
not let me go please
I mean my husband here get him I can't I
need to talk to my husband I need to
hold my husband Peter consciousness get
him
can you at least try did this seem take
a lot out of you I think I went and
slept after this when you do those
scenes it kind of is that thing of
weighing up to that day doing it because
you can't if it was the nervous thing of
not knowing if it's gonna come mmm right
and that is like the day that what if it
just doesn't work because you act a lot
but I must say when it comes to that
kind of height of emotion it just
becomes very physical so when you reach
a certain point you know know what it's
gonna happen anymore it was a director
that I worked with last year who asked
me it's like when did you cry the last
time and I was like well I did in an
enrolled and he was like no not you and
it's that thing and I think a lot of
people are very embarrassed to cry in
public or in front of even people that
you know or care about and and and and
and when it actually kind of holds
together but I wrote I do remember it's
like three years ago and I was by myself
it was one thing that happened my life
and I suddenly I was watching Simpsons
it was the weirdest thing it was a thing
that I had Holden and then just came out
and then it's like a child it's like so
much energy that comes and then
afterwards I'm like I was so tired so
yeah I think I had a lunch I'm went up
and a little bit for people who have
seen the whole film they know that
eventually Gerda is the ultimate support
for Lily someone who completely supports
her in all of her life decisions who is
that person in your life my mom my dad
my closest to three friends I had a
friend who called me and just like I
thought you just let's just FaceTime and
she was like we don't need to chat and
she just told me see like how the screen
on and she was I just think you just
need to hang out for a bit and in the
end I was like the biggest little gift
but she just knew that we should just
like hang out okay
well it's been a pleasure getting to
know you and to celebrate your amazing
accomplishments in this movie so
congratulations and it's great to see
you well thank you and if you have not
seen the Danish girl be sure
get your tickets on Fandango and watch
it so you can appreciate all the amazing
things that Alyssia did and thanks so
much for watching
Fandango frontrunners
you